this is the last picture taken of dyay
kofuku Maru or the Lucky Dragon number
five a Japanese tuna fishing boat in
1954
shortly after this picture was taken it
would carry a crew of 23 men and set
sail to the Marshall Islands what
happened there was a catastrophic
disaster that shook the nation of Japan
to its core and contributed to the
creation of one of the most iconic
monsters in cinema history
[Music]
August 1945 the history of the world was
forever changed by the atomic bombings
of Hiroshima and Nagasaki after
suffering more than 220,000 casualties
the Empire of Japan announced its
surrender leading to the end of World
War two the US forces quickly moved in
to launch Operation blacklist a mission
to demilitarize in democratize Japan
during the next years of occupation the
u.s. strictly prohibited any news
coverage that dealt with the aftermath
of the atomic bombings this meant the
rise in radiation related illnesses
birth defects and the long-term effects
on the surrounding regions were
effectively silenced to help the u.s.
maintain its authority and even after
the occupation came to an end in 1952
several japanese activists and
journalists began dealing more directly
with the effects of the atom bomb but
they weren't able to gain much traction
and it all seemed as though it would be
forgotten until January 22nd 1954 when
Lucky Dragon number 5 the small Japanese
tuna fishing boat departed the harbors
of Yazoo for a routine fishing job with
a crew of 23 men the Lucky Dragon number
5 set off fishing in a Midway sea near
the Midway at all but soon after the
boat altered its course south toward the
Marshall Islands just 80 miles west of
its destination lay the bikini adil an
island famous for America's testing of
various nuclear weapons including Castle
Bravo which is today the most powerful
nuclear device ever detonated by the
United States the Castle Bravo was
scheduled for testing on March 1st 1954
the same day that Lucky Dragon number
five arrived at the Marshall Islands the
US government had already declared in
advance a 57,000 square mile danger zone
that could potentially be affected by
the fallout but what they were not able
to predict in advance was the sheer
power of Castle Bravo
the test proved to be more than twice as
powerful as the initial prediction and
changes in weather patterns blew the
nuclear fallout far outside the danger
zone where the Lucky Dragon number five
had been sailing within hours of testing
the ship was engulfed into fine ashes of
radioactive fallout or what the
fisherman called Shino hai the death ash
they immediately returned to Izu but by
then it was too late
all 23 fishermen had fallen ill to acute
radiation syndrome and their story
quickly became a sensation gripping the
nation in fear and panic the incident of
Lucky Dragon number 5 sparked a national
anti-nuclear movement and at the height
of fear and panic just eight months
after the incident the 1954 original
Gojira arrived at the theatres with an
opening scene that hit close to home
[Music]
the original Gojira was not meant to be
a fantasy blockbuster but a horror movie
especially in the eyes of the Japanese
people who had already witnessed a
similar destruction Godzilla was a
symbol of thermonuclear weapons as well
as a victim an intentional directorial
decision by director Akira Honda who
explained I took the characteristics of
an atomic bomb and applied them to
Gojira
it's skin texture was modeled to closely
resemble the keloid scars of the
Hiroshima bombing survivors and its
signature weapon an atomic heat beam was
generated by the nuclear energy inside
the creature and unleashed through its
jaw to bring destruction to the cities
of Japan
Gojira unleashed brutality in a way that
hadn't been captured in cinema before
unflinching senseless and in
discriminatory a majority of the movies
are nothing more than the reactions of
people helpless as they watch the
destruction unfold director Honda a
former soldier of world war ii who had
passed through the devastation of the
atom bomb in Hiroshima closely
referenced his experience and lio photos
of the ruins in post-war Japan to bring
a sense of realism to the destruction
left by the creature but this was not
the same Gojira that most Western
audiences remember when an American
studio bought the distribution rights
for Gojira nearly 16 minutes of the film
deemed unnecessary were edited out and
canadian-american actor Raymond Burr was
brought in to play an American
journalist adding new scenes that would
tell the story from the perspective of
an outsider looking in rather than the
people experiencing the attack using
body doubles matching dresses and other
camera trickery to make the inclusion
seamless and the simple title Gojira was
changed to Godzilla king of the monsters
a horror movie that peered into the
Japanese people's fear of radiation and
the potential long-term effects of the
atom bomb was mutated into a generic
monster movie
shunt by critics and ironically this was
the version that introduced Godzilla to
the world and the only version that
critics and scholars had access to until
2004 and it shocked many who remembered
Gojira is a silly monster movie with a
rubber dinosaur suit when they
discovered that it was in fact a sombre
allegory to the horrors that not many
had been able to experience firsthand
and this allegory becomes more evident
toward the end of the movie when a
scientist accidentally discovers a more
powerful devastating weapon known as the
oxygen destroyer that could potentially
kill Godzilla and bring an end to the
destruction he is hesitant in using it
worried it could potentially be used as
a weapon against men this all culminates
into a powerful message at the end when
Godzilla the embodiment of the atom bomb
comes full circle to become the victim
of another terrifying weapon this also
marks one of the very few instances
where Godzilla actually dies in its own
film and perhaps this is why Godzilla
has stood the test of time to become one
of the most influential and iconic
monster franchises of our generation it
follows a simple rule that makes any
monster in cinema memorable it's based
on our real fears
you